a great honor to have the crown prince
with us
the trump white house was willing to do
business with the saudi crown prince
this despite his alleged involvement in
the murder of journalist jamal khashoggi
which then president donald trump
brushed away
now the new administration says
president biden will conduct
any conversation with saudi arabia on
what it calls
a counterpart to counterpart basis the
president's counterpart is king salman
and i expect at an appropriate time he
would have a conversation with him i
don't have a prediction of the timeline
on that
that system 13 billion dollars
the biden administration is conducting a
review of the arms sales at the previous
administration signed with saudi arabia
and has already made clear it will no
longer offer any backing
for saudi-led operations against the
houthis in neighboring yemen
recalibration is a very good word on the
one hand
there are still overlapping interests
obviously uh
the united states shares the saudi
concern about iran
and and the united states continues to
support
a process that the saudi arabia has
quietly supported
in terms of normalization of relations
between the region
and israel president biden has also
signaled that his administration will
place a far
greater focus on human rights than did
the previous one
and in this it's significant that the
director of national intelligence avril
haynes
has indicated that she would be prepared
to share the cia report
on the murder of jamal khashoggi with
congress
this too is something the previous
administration blocked from happening
despite bipartisan demands since coming
to power the biden administration has
repeatedly used the term
security partner with regard to saudi
arabia
removing the word ally that was
preferred by
then president trump but despite this
recalibration the biden administration
has also made clear that it sees
a good relationship with saudi arabia as
in the u.s
national interest particularly as it
negotiates the stormy waters
of formulating a new relationship with
iran
mike hanna al jazeera washington